so what Kramer's rule does for us is it
allows us to use determinants okay to
solve a system of equations so here's
the formula over here I've just written
this in a generic form but I'll explain
what how to do it it's very easy all you
have to do is the denominators okay so
we're trying to solve for x and y the
denominators what you want to do is you
want to make a matrix okay using the
coefficients okay the numbers in front
of the variables so we've got a B D and
E so you can see a B D and E a B D and E
those are okay the matrices we're going
to use for the denominator and what
these bars represent is that we're going
to be taking the determinant of that
matrix now the numerator is what you
want to do okay and you'll notice this
here is that the solutions okay C and F
when we're solving for x you want to put
CNF in place of the coefficients okay
that are in front of that the X
variables but when you're solving for y
you're going to want to replace the
coefficients okay B and E with the
solutions C and F everything else is the
same so if you want to think of an easy
way of doing this just take the
coefficients a B Dini
write that four times one two three four
okay
but when you solve for X replace those
coefficients here with the solutions
when you're solving for y replace the Y
coefficients here with the solutions
then all you have to do is take the
determinant of the numerator take the
determinant the denominator divided and
you've got it so I'll show you what I
mean in these next couple of examples so
we're trying to solve this system of
equations here so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to set up Kramer's rule
we've got x equals the determinant of
okay do the numerator denominator and
I'll do the same thing for y so I'll
show you kind of how we work through
this so for the denominator we're just
going to use 1 negative 2 3 and 1 1
negative 2 3 and 1 okay but for the
numerators when we solve for X we're
gonna replace the X coefficients with
the solutions we solve for y we're going
to replace the Y coefficients with the
solutions and then we're going to
proceed here so we've got negative 2 and
1 here we have 1 & 3
ok sorry with me so far okay so now
we're just going to take the determinant
so that
it's a didi okay minus BC so we've got
negative three minus negative ten
okay so negative three minus negative
ten
okay divided by one minus negative six
okay so if we simplify this this comes
out to let's see this is 7 this is 7 so
we get one
okay now the denominator here is going
to be the same as the denominator here
so we can save a little bit of work by
just saying this is seven but the
numerator is going to be 5 minus
negative 9 which is 14 divided by 7
which is 2 so the solution to this
system is going to be 1 comma 2